don't make me pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare oh man and when I get promoted
you're full fired if you get promoted
ah don't make me prefire you you
wouldn't dare you're pre-fired and when
I'm promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted
shoot oh it's just like the old days Joe
is coming later to I cannot have a
subordinate trying to make me look
stupid okay I need you to promise me
that you'll be on your best behavior I
promised other people that I'd be on my
worst behavior and I gave my word so
don't make me fire you you can't fire me
you're acting manager not office manager
so you have no firing Powers don't make
me pre-fire you you wouldn't dare watch
this you're pre-fired and when I'm
promoted you'll be full
fired if you get promoted and if you
haven't fallen in love with me by then
what I am all about Pilates okay there
are four tenants I live by one lengthen
two a long game I can do
that all right guys I think we
all oh I'll tell you what it's not even
just about
strength it's not about strength it's
about skill I'm taking karate classes
online my sense it
just
tell you this Dwight but big biceps are
considered womanish they're basically
just arm tits oh
really yeah it's like two boobs why
don't you tell that to the great apes
have you seen their biceps yeah you're
talking silver back I'm the silver back
you're just a little chimp throwing
feces at himself look at your face
you're a
disgrace
yep
really yeah I remember when biceps were
all the rage uh dakus had just announced
his candidacy for
[Music]
governor man my DS are
blasted I wish they had a chart for how
much protein powder to scoop for a 180
lb man with no fat protein powder huh
cut it with water water why don't you
just take
estrogen there you go boys see how Papa
takes care of you you got to find it
before it eggs describe it brown shiny
painful bite could be an Elm Weevil
describe its mood did
it an Elm Weevil describe it brown shiny
painful bite could be a bat Weevil
describe it
describe it uh Brown shiny painful bite
could be a bat
Weevil describe it brown shiny painful
bite could be a warble describe its mood
did it
seems but after I bit you did it run
away fearful or did it walk away smug
selfish so smug like this like he
thought it was
funny that was good oh that was that was
good oh that was really delicious and
where did you see it in the bed well I
haven't seen anything we got to find it
before it
eggs describe it brown shiny painful
bite could be a bat Weevil describe its
mood did it seem sleepy stressed but to
be fair it was a tense situation fair
enough but after a bit you did it run
away fearful or did it walk away smug
self assured so smug like he thought it
was funny like this
that's a bed bug yeah everything's a
joke I know check Michael it's okay 2
minutes is too soon 5 minutes and two
minutes is a very big difference you
going hold it together right
[Laughter]
now I told you to war me 5 minutes what
happened to four and three because 2
minutes doesn't do us any good come here
got hold it together
okay how we doing on contractions two
minutes apart two minutes oh
God I told you no I told you to warm me
at 5 minutes we waited too long I know
we waited too long 2 minutes doesn't do
us any good well what happened to four
in three minutes okay Jim eat spicy
foods what is the opposite of that make
spicy foods come out of her okay nope
no eat spicy foods okay okay what is the
opposite of that make spicy foods come
out of her nope okay nope nope we're not
doing that Pam
okay so what is it eat spicy foods and
the opposite of that oh make spicy
food where are we we have every six
minutes ladies and gentlemen another 75
contractions and you are going to be
there for the love of God Pam do it for
Ultra Feast okay you know what I'm going
to go give uh Dr rosani a quick call
he'll probably know Jim please happy
thoughts here happy times yeah Happy
Times come on let's have Happy Times Jim
as a matter of
fact I printed out 10 ways to induce
labor and I'm thinking we just do the
opposite of those things and we can slow
down your labor Aon read the first one
okay um stimulate the nipples okay
nobody touch Pam's nipples think of
Pam's nipples as Toby's grundle her
shirt is touching them maybe we should
cut holes in her shirt I have a shirt
like that in my car okay yeah why don't
you go get it okay uh the second one is
walk around we're already doing the
opposite of that perfect okay uh number
three eat spicy foods okay the opposite
of that stick spicy food up her butt
nope nope nope nope we just want to say
we're very sorry screw you guys you're
dead to me if you say screw you one more
time screw you beat whoa okay
guys I did the face you like if you say
screw you one more time screw you beat
Farm
guys stop doing that it makes no sense
if you say screw you one more time you
be hey guys just cool
it you knew you knew that one was dead
we just want to say we are very sorry
screw you guys you're dead to me if you
say screw you one more time screw you be
I forget your birthday I would never do
that guys we just want to make it up to
you what can we
do I guess my only wish would be that
nothing so terrible would ever happen to
anyone else ever again oh God okay in a
way it's good that it happened to me
because at least I
what kind of cake do you want
imbecile ice cream basically the
Dynamics
of all right basically within the
[Laughter]
workplace go go ahead you do it okay I
insist basically after phis blackmailed
Angela Michael asked them both to step
down from the party planning committee
cuz there was too much drama what he
said was easy there was a problem with
having one head of the party planning
committee she becomes too powerful so we
appointed two
heads party planning I'm a this
literally the stupidest
humiliating that's on my
side so this is
fun there's always a theme idiot
[Laughter]
and
Tada I hate it how do you hate it it's a
cake well there's no flowers or toys or
I mean there's nothing on it where did
you even find a cake like this I mean
doesn't have my name on it do you guys
know what my name is my name is Kelly
right I forgot if there was an e between
the L and the Y I still don't know I
mean I don't even know what this theme
is what's the
theme SP frosting those aren't
themes there's always a
theme there's always a theme I guess
what surround sound means is that right
over here
CH two
speakers damn we have two
speakers what honey oh Jesus this is
terrible we'll never finish this episode
um check this out
folds the
wall sorry oh my God I finally broke
down and bought myself a plasma
TV check it out I actually hung this on
the wall myself it's good want to show
you something a lot of people in the
room you need more space voila right
into the wall wow sometimes I will just
stand here and watch television for
hours I love it I love this
TV